this is a piece called and you this was
written by again an awardwinning poet so
this is like this guy's at the top of
the game for poetry these days and
here's a poem I will I will recite it to
you a little poodle runs to show you
love you like the feel of the animal's
body on your leg it's something of an
acceptance so you smile and are not the
least bit bothered you even hope it'll
jump it's just that everybody how do you
explain this there's nobody to explain
it to knew why she needed to take away
from you this one feeling of special how
could she know it was the most human
moment of your day the less Discerning
listener may be fooled into thinking
that that poem is better than it really
is because of my beautiful raw uh
nuanced performance which elevated the
material uh but if you can look past my
unmistakable talents as a Slam Poet
you'll see that this is just absolute
drek